so after finishing the New Avengers
incursions I was sitting here thinking
that story was very very dark that story
was very I guess gritty in terms of how
it was done it was basically about
ending other universes and I thought it
you know doing the house of M would be
just as dark so I figured why not
lighten up the tone why not make things
more interesting by bringing to you guys
the second part of the deadpool killa g'
deadpool killa straighted now the reason
why i say is the second part is because
there is a trilogy among the deadpool
series called deadpool killa g of course
the first part was Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe the second part is of
course as we're going to discuss here
the Deadpool Killa straited and the
third part is a Deadpool kills Deadpool
now for those of you guys that didn't
see our initial video or initial series
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe what
we had found was that Deadpool's mind
had been tampered with by psycho man but
all this had taken place in an alternate
reality and indeed this trilogy doesn't
tie into the main earth-616 universe yet
it's really just standalone it's just
kind of out there by itself but what
Deadpool had realized what his mind had
been tampered with was that Deadpool and
other superheroes were the creation and
the I guess concepts of various writers
were simply being manipulated for the
purpose of what he perceived to be the
writers own desire for violence and
things like that and so as Deadpool felt
it is not the role of anyone as I guess
as he perceives it to be under the
control of anybody else and so what he
sees himself doing is effectively flight
like freeing these superheroes the best
way I can describe it it's his way of
basically taking them away from being a
slave to the writers and giving them
freedom and the only way you can really
do that in terms of how we can
rationalize it is to kill them so so
what we do here as we pick up with
Deadpool killest rated is that we pick
up with issue number one and we find
ourselves going back to the multiverse
now as it stands right now
Deadpool's within the Baxter building
and one of the alternate realities and
he's simply using the Baxter building as
a I guess as a base of operations and
what we find is that Deadpool has been
traversing the multiverse since the end
of Deadpool kills the universe kills the
Marvel Universe issue number four and
what he's been doing is killing
countless versions of other superheroes
but the more he thinks about it the more
he believes this might be a futile
effort and so what he considers doing is
killing himself but what the voice the I
guess the psychotic voice of Deadpool in
his head tells him is that if he did
that it may very well be possible that
he's free of the control of these people
who were creating him and if he is then
he may just be able to rest he may not
have to worry about being revived but if
he's not and in some way he's going to
be brought back in and this is the way
that the Marvel I guess the the Marvel
Deadpool killest rated writers are
poking fun at the idea that when a
character is popular there will always
be some method of bringing them back
they'll be cloned or they're simply just
be revived outright or there'll be some
kind of story that's thrown in there
haphazardly this kind of shoehorned into
tell us well this character wasn't
really dead the whole time or this is
some other version of that character and
so what this voice and Deadpool's head
tells him is the only way to truly win
is to kill the source but we don't
exactly know what that means yet but we
find out what this means when we travel
to travel with deadpool when he goes to
meet various supervillains that he's
basically kidnapped and forced into
servitude and then it appears as far as
we can tell the leader of this group of
supervillains is the mad thinker of
course one of the foremost enemies of
the Fantastic Four and what the
madfinger tells deadpool is that they've
discovered a pocket multiverse called
the idea verse and this is where
basically all the literary classics are
at this is where Don Quixote Moby Dick
Sleepy Hollow this is where all those
stories are from and this is where the
creators are drawing their inspiration
for creating various superheroes and so
the rationale is that if Deadpool goes
back and he kills all these characters
before the creators could actually come
into contact with them or can actually
read about them then there'll be no
basis for these superheroes and so by
virtue of a paradox these superheroes
will simply cease to exist now the
possibility also exists that Deadpool
will die in return but as far as
Deadpool is concerned this
major issue but one of the things I
guess of the mad thinker tells Deadpool
is that because this is a multiverse
there are layers of realities on top of
one another and that if you were to go
poking around and changing things it
could be like messing up a Jenga set in
the sense that he could pull out the
wrong piece and the whole thing could
come toppling down but again this isn't
something Deadpool is concerned about
and so what Deadpool does is he decides
to undertake this role of trying to
learn about the classics rather than
going through actually just killing
everybody arbitrarily and so what he
does is he travels to the library which
of course he says is the one place he
fears to go the most and what he does in
the library is he tries to read up on
these various literary classics but what
he finds here is that each just getting
really really bored and so the only
thing he can really do as far as he's
concerned to Ale his boredom is to
simply just go through and just kill
everybody just to basically make it easy
and so what happens here is Deadpool
travels back to the Baxter building and
he begins talking with the mad thinker
again and again what Deadpool has done
here as he has basically taken the nexus
of realities from the Florida Everglades
where he had previously traveled at the
end of Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe and brings that to the Baxter
building and basically creates a portal
whereby he can travel through and then
get to the idea the idea verse and so
what happens here is he tells the
supervillains that he's very proud of
the work that they've done he's very
glad they've put their best effort or
their best foot forward and says that
he's left them a parting gift and so
after he departs to leave for the idea
verse we find out from the mad thinker
that the supervillains have actually
been orchestrating a plan to eliminate
Deadpool now they don't know exactly
where Deadpool will go they don't know
how long he will be there he may be back
in simple moments I don't really know
how time works in the idea verse and so
what they say is they have to work quick
but then we find out what the parting
gift was a Deadpool had left him which
was a series of robots with razor blades
for hands but go through and basically
just start killing all the villains and
so that's the gift that he left them and
so what happens here is Deadpool lands
in Spain in 1610 and what he does is he
encounters Don Quixote and Sancho Panza
now for those of you guys who never read
about Don
hoody this is hailed as a great literary
classic and this is what we're going to
see in this story we're gonna see
Deadpool encountering all these great
literary classics and then basically
killing the characters and this is what
he does when he encounters Don Quixote
Don Quixote initially runs Deadpool
through with a spear but he doesn't
understand why Deadpool doesn't die and
so what Deadpool what Deadpool tells Don
Quixote is that he has something in his
eye and he uses his knife to get it out
but what he actually ends up doing is
just gouging the eye out of a Adam Don
Quixote from here he goes through and
actually kills Don Quixote and then when
he comes across a Sancho Panza who's
discovered the fact that Deadpool's
killed Don Quixote he possibly just
kills Sancho Panza without really
worrying too much about who he is and
this is really kind of poking fun at the
character of Sancho Pazza
and the reason why is because when
people think of Don Quixote they know
right off the bat who Don Quixote is a
guy who's disconnected with reality and
can't really place himself and where he
is at that particular point in time but
no one remembers the name of his
sidekick no one knows who his name is in
fact I didn't actually thought it was
Pancho and I had to go look it up but in
any event what we do from here is we
travel to to 1850 and what we find here
is that deadpool has basically killed
moby dick now initially what we find is
that is that the I guess the Pequod the
ship is being captained by Captain Ahab
who is trying to find Moby Dick comes
across the corpse of Moby Dick and when
he surprised here is the fact that
somebody else has killed Moby Dick
besides him and so what happens is
Deadpool cuts his way out of the top of
Moby Dick and then Captain Ahab has
wrote as a Deadpool brought on board and
somebody tells Deadpool is that he's
extending his hospitality to him and he
wants to know why it is a Deadpool has
killed Moby Dick
but before Deadpool starts answering any
questions he starts killing all the crew
of the Pequod now initially he attempts
to kill a Captain Ahab but what we find
here is that before we get too much
further with this we jump to London in
1865 and what we find is that we're
joining Sherlock Holmes and the reason
why is because the mad thinker has been
able to code a message and send it to
just Sherlock Holmes in the idea verse
and what he basically does here is
explain every
thing that Deadpool is doing the idea
that Deadpool believes that he's simply
just some kind of puppet for the scheme
of his creators and that by going back
and killing the various characters in
this idea verse that he can a
retroactive Lee kill off all the
superheroes that currently exist and so
what Sherlock Holmes does is he seems to
take this information into account but
we actually won't find out until the end
of this story what action he takes and
so what we do is we jump back to the
Pequod and what we find is that again
Deadpool is going through and killing
all the crew members of the Pequod but
what he does after he's done with them
is he sets his sights on Captain Ahab
and this is one of the interesting
things and this is going to be a theme
that we see ongoing with regards to
Deadpool killest rated what happens as
Deadpool is getting ready to kill
Captain Ahab as I kept in Captain Ahab
initially I guess for a split second
takes on the form of general Thunderbolt
Ross in his human form and then takes on
the form of Red Hulk and the reason why
is because those characters or I guess
the character of general Thunderbolt
Ross is in a lot of ways modeled after
Captain Ahab in the sense that the
Incredible Hulk is the Moby Dick
of of general Thunderbolt Ross and so
what happens here is before Deadpool is
actually able to kill Captain Ahab the
Nautilus arrives of course the ship that
was very famed and piloted by a Captain
Nemo then what happens here is the
Nautilus seems to maybe rescue or at the
very least attempt to apprehend Deadpool
and and Captain Ahab and it's using some
sort of tentacles to grab the two of
them and so what happens is before other
tentacles can basically impale Deadpool
and possibly destroy his physical body
Deadpool teleports away and so what
happens here in one of my favorite
moments actually in the entire Deadpool
Killa straighted story is we switch to
Missouri to st. Petersburg Missouri and
what we do here is we pick up with Tom
Sawyer but we don't actually see Tom
Sawyer all we see is a Tom Sawyer
appears to be painting a fence and he's
going about I guess talking the way he
did back in in these stories during the
Mark Twain novel and he was talking
about how he enjoys this kind of thing
and that it's not really a chore for him
but if it is a chore then he'll do more
of it and then he takes notice of a man
who's walking towards him and he talked
about how this man is dressed very
strangely
suddenly we see a splash of blood on the
fence indicating to us that Deadpool has
just killed Tom Sawyer and so from here
we jump from Tom Sawyer to Dracula
now Deadpool is initial encounter with
Dracula or at least as far as
information about Dracula is concerned
seems to be tied more into mainstream
films and so what he tells Dracula is
that he's nothing like what he had seen
in the movies and he says it's no wonder
why people like the idea of Edward
Cullen as a vampire as opposed to this
actual Bram Stoker Dracula type of
character and so what he says is that
he's 100% Team Jacob which I disagree
with I'm a hundred percent Team Edward
but the fact remains that what happens
here is Dracula calls on his his Brides
to attack Deadpool and a Deadpool of
course is able to overpower these brides
and then he turns the sights on Dracula
now dragula seems to turn into a dr.
strange here in fact I can't really
think who else this would be besides
Doctor Strange unless maybe it's a it's
Morpheus or somebody like that but what
happens here is a Deadpool basically
kills them off panel we don't actually
see him killing any of them what we see
is that his Deadpool is travelling
continuing along this path and talking
to the psychotic voice in his head that
he's decapitated all of them it seems to
just throw their heads off the side of a
cliff and so what we do from here is we
see that a Deadpool appears to encounter
a Ghost Rider and this is really
interesting to us because we know this
as far as I'm concerned as far as I'm
aware anyway there have been other
versions of Ghost Rider and so this may
legitimately be an instance where by he
encounters Ghost Rider but what happens
here is that this Ghost Rider seems to
be Johnny Blaze and Johnny Blaze didn't
exist at this particular point in time
which turns out to be a New York in a
Sleepy Hollow of course this in reality
turns out to be the the Headless
Horseman which of course again is the
character that that Ghost Rider is
modeled after and so what happens here
is what's revealed I guess is that the
the Headless Horseman is actually Brom
and of course we knew that this was this
was Brom of course those of us who would
register on oh that Brom was the one who
would scared Ichabod Crane away and so
what happens here is Brom is taken by
surprise
by the fact that the Deadpool turns out
to be an actual villain somebody that
would really try to kill him and so what
Deadpool does is he taunts Brown for a
bit then he asks Brom if what he was
wanting to be was really the headless
horseman and so what he does is he
decapitates Brom and then puts candles
in his head and tells him that his wish
has been granted
and so what we do is we transition back
to London with Sherlock Holmes and what
we find here is that Sherlock Holmes has
called a called a group together and
this group of course consists of a
Moulin consists of Beowulf and others
which are going to be a way for Sherlock
Holmes to get this group together for
the purpose of tracking down Deadpool
and ultimately trying to defeat him with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly